this week we've got picture day the
worst day
dodging a service and stinky Josh
favorite this first store you guys is my
[ __ ] favorite ever I saw this and I
was laughing for day picture days
laughing like five minutes yeah I took a
thousand hour nap five minutes of
laughing is a good [ __ ] laugh yeah
and then I kept looking at this and I
just kept laughing even more all right
so this mom sent her kid to school on
picture day with the green shirt green
that the green like the [ __ ] marble in
the background to try to make you look
fancy no no it's like it's all green on
green screen but lasers is the [ __ ] in
the back dude now that [ __ ] we're going
lean against the tree with the [ __ ]
that was too new for my era oh really
what you guys have yeah would you have
like a marble back my mind was blue you
had three options like purple barbels
oh yeah yeah it was red blue or yeah
yeah I think so
it was so corny I didn't have a tree or
blue backdrop with my bull cut it was
from the marble and then the laser is
the lasers was the [ __ ] back and they
would always do this like right after
recess or lunch so everyone had sweat
wings like right here yeah I thought
this mom she posted on Facebook she says
my son mom I shouldn't have worn the
green shirt for pictures it will blend
in with the green screen they used me
what they used this green screen I
probably should have read some fine
print maybe they they will be okay no
shits and emojis seriously cracking up
at least his hair and smile were on
point which one should we choose oh
that's sick though that's
looks like a mean yeah yeah that's
hilarious
[Laughter]
I died I like out of the [ __ ] for
like whoever did this [ __ ] it is it like
is it a team or is it just like one dude
or like I don't know a few times right a
polo shirt though yeah see like one
button American flag and in the fall -
American flag I'm kind of partial to the
flag yeah and this is the truth I like
that one the best
that's a good astronaut he looked like
he got a hole in the flag and stuck his
head and you know when he showed up the
cameraman's like you [ __ ] idiot never
been the mom says she asked around and
there was no notice of don't worry
no [ __ ] way no way I've been waiting
for this day he's been waiting you know
I bet he made some shitty like really
shitty edits to send his friends look
[ __ ] kid yeah yeah I feel like the
green matched the background - yeah it's
like perfectly the same color
oh yes the colour that cos yeah
photographer just didn't expect anyone
have a shirt that color I like those
arms just pop out I had a green shirt
you know intermediate school damn love
this green shirt so that would have been
me I have a green screen for my stream
yeah I know I've seen it I love it my
background is basically just a collage
of the dumb faces that I make so if I
were to wear a green like shirt and it's
just me I like just blend in
I know I haven't cuz I don't own
anything green but I really want to we
gotta get you something green one like a
turtleneck I mean is blended well I
gotta get it you're matching something
now be real cool like like if you if you
become an American flag like through
your whole stream mm-hmm we had a great
day when that kid liked it do you guys
have your old elementary school yeah all
of them I got some of them here really
where your photos shitty cuz I can
you're a kid you don't know how to
[ __ ] smile properly man yeah my my
smiles were always like this Yeah right
that was all yeah mine was always some
of my clothes were [ __ ] [ __ ] - I
saw this one picture of me I had a polo
shirt on and then I had long johns
coming out from underneath you know yeah
well you can tell your mom made you wear
long johns probably want me to be like
warm or whatever but you can also tell
that I slept in them so they're baggy
long with the [ __ ] droopy sleeve I
feel like that was a style like a
thermal like a thermal underneath and
it's he on top I'll rock that's it yeah
now look at the sky did that do anything
with anything even like a button-up no I
think it was a style they tried to bring
back the [ __ ] like spaghetti set a
strap dress with the t-shirt underneath
for chicks man why are you doing it
she's more in that chair really I can't
Moroccan people like it's the nineties
he saw solder got horny I mean it looks
great on YouTube no I agree I didn't
like it I just I'd rather show my
shoulders but no I remember my third
grade photo I that's around the time
when I didn't realize that so I played
with my mom's razor and I realized that
the cap was it on and I shaved off like
parts of my eyebrows so we took photos
like I still have those photos because I
tried destroying them I just really want
to see this I tried that I tried to
destroy them all but my mom saved one
that's good that's good that they died
her mom did that my eyebrows were so
[ __ ]
and obviously you were born to be a
chola that's what you were it was your
calling the [ __ ]
little bangs still on that one no he
knows only first cream you should have
tried to draw the rest of your eyebrow
[Music]
but instead we went to go get glasses
and I got these big old circle blesses
and I swore that they covered my
fucked-up eye weight she got your
glasses instead of drawing I'm solving
is not quite her forte not really no
gotcha we got through this mustache I'll
distract away from losers just shave
your head she could have been like you
know just shave off all your completely
ever knows I'm saying it was your chola
your inner chola calling you know it's
the cult you know what they're more
stupid I didn't do it won it twice yeah
I didn't learn my lesson oh damn it's
Curtis how did you survive this long you
know and we did that every day you think
huh no no no I know but I think school
photos oh I forgot what great it would
do I have what I have what I still have
it I don't have it on this wallet but
boy he looks [ __ ] funny cuz he got a
fucked-up haircut so his hair is all
[ __ ] up and then his face was like he
laughs at that photo to every school
photo that's [ __ ] up you just look
like a mad TV character yeah true -
alright the bride next story the writer
of crazy rich Asians is wanted in
Singapore for dodging national service
Kevin Kwan one because they all have to
serve in the army
yes and the national service everyone
done that no I forgot they had a
military well I mean like if I was the
president of Singapore though I'd be
like it's cool cuz he doesn't look like
he could serve you know to me like he's
like one of those dudes that you're like
you probably not gonna do well know the
reason why you Josh's because we moved
to the US but why do I get after him now
like
yeah I think he's putting your country
on the map
it could be one of those things like a
warrant like it's just on your record it
is it's like been there since 1999
because we have a few friends in like
that that are that had to do it in Korea
or something like that because if they
have a mandatory one to examine II can't
fly back in though but it's usually like
they don't usually go out of their
country it's just the next time you go
and visit they just say snatch you up
just like a fine or something so he's
facing a fine ten thousand Singapore
dollars which is about seven thousand
three hundred eighty dollars and a
possible prison service of up to three
years nevermind if he steps foot in
Singapore yes so he just had some that
stuff wouldn't you know maybe I guess he
didn't he didn't do any um like he
wasn't doing any of the film stuff out
there huh because he filmed out there
maybe just didn't go you might have just
not gone the phone he wrote the books
but he's that part of the movie you know
his his hair looks like the type of hair
that Asian female lawyers will say
century 21 logo on it and then that's
his but that's what I'm saying if I was
the president of Singapore I'd excuse
them cuz I'd just be like man you don't
I get you I know who you are you know
like you're a theater kid you're right
you're not someone that's gonna do well
in the military he's marketing your
country the right way yeah and he's
doing a great job it's like everybody's
in it yeah
that happened here with Muhammad Ali
during the Vietnam War you try to get
away from the draft they throw him in
jail
oh yeah yeah but I mean I want Muhammad
Ali in our military you know to me like
he's like he's yeah I don't want him to
die but maybe he could do something like
I don't know like the cook or something
I don't know wait what would you want
him in your military then it could fight
yeah this dude could look at me clearly
conditions his hair he's not meant for
the military no Muhammad though like you
could count that you count on that even
if he's the cook right like if he gets
attacked he's still making burgers he
don't give a [ __ ] he wasn't she's not
gonna run away so in your scenario still
he's not fighting oh my god imagine him
I want him to save his hands and life
imagine him cooking on their own cookie
dough but okay so all I'm saying is if
the enemy attacks yeah he's not gonna
drop the spatula and run what if the
military work that way though like now
you're making us feel like ants like all
right like you're jacked you're going to
the [ __ ] army like you're [ __ ] go
to here the chef you get to go yeah dude
like I'm a [ __ ] dude I have a little
bit of muscle but I'm a big [ __ ] I'm
gonna go to war but will you abandon
your friends don't know I would never
been in my friends over my country but
I'm not trying to go I'd be pissed that
I'd have to protect my friends like [ __ ]
did you better have that haircut all
right a get back because there are so
many other jobs I just remembered when
we were in Korea we saw one of the most
prettiest man cops Wow you look like a
kpop star but because everyone has to
serve in the South Korean army right so
like but there's other jobs like you can
work security you could probably do
admin or whatever did he did he have
handcuffs whoa whoa he was a huge users
are really pretty dude I was a military
police Thien looks like a kpop no I just
like pretty men that's awesome
me too me like we got like that you guys
could share no that's weird
no but he looked like he could have been
a kpop star like and he's just walking
around in and he's doing his military
leasing thing right so I'm like okay
yeah maybe he should have served them
because there's so many other jobs he
doesn't have to be like fighting for
Singapore we think anyone gets by well
they did like a kpop star what if hear
kpop sorry I like Jason Holliday
they actually there's scandal in kpop
that if you don't go you're not like
what do you call it like you're yeah
you're not patriotic and then they look
down on you and all that stuff overseas
like a more Western I think Europe is
often like you either go to school or
you got a surfer to you yeah but you
don't have to serve you know what I mean
so do one of the other I think Kevin
Kwan is a Singapore citizen like he's
not an American citizen in 1994 he did
apply to appeal to renounce his
Singapore citizenship but it was
rejected so I guess he's still a no he
tried to become not citizen yeah you're
trying to denounce it no it was in a and
it's all like the reason he was doing
that was because he didn't want to go
through the national service commitment
mmm then it was turned down because he
didn't do the name some countries they
have like a limit to their like once
like you're 40 or something then they
don't care about this dude's 44 oh damn
gangster what as money as jail yeah
[ __ ] yeah we are saying that that's
[ __ ] up not only do you have to pay
but you have to do time there hmm so
Singaporean yeah what if you just pay
your way out man they [ __ ] you up if you
chew gum they got like a black market
for gum out there mm-hmm they're so
strict never been there I want to go
it's [ __ ] awesome and be mandatory
service pretty tight though I don't I
feel like all nations should have it it
builds like some sort of movie you
should be like mainly you knew there's
everyone do it if it was chicks that
would be so [ __ ] cuz I think everyone
you don't have to go to the same branch
are you know like Air Force Nate or
whatever but it'd be cool if you chose
one that you best suited you but I think
it teaches you like like team mentality
how to fight for greater cause and
teaches you discipline there's like so
many dope lessons that you learn in it
that people miss out on new you always
care for someone you work for it or like
are you a part of it yeah so you care
maybe more about your country you're
like thanks or people didn't didn't have
a chance to play a team sport like now
they can play another team sport no
that's so true because I wanted to join
the military just like a shoe people
legally and learn how to do all kinds of
cool like survival skills and all that
but then I learned
about like how you don't have any
choices and you just gotta do whatever
that you're told and I was like [ __ ]
that I rather not alright for our last
story this British Airways flight
attendant has been grounded after you're
good you can get grounded well that's a
big meet think she can't fly oh oh no
more people to your room oh that's
probably where the grounded can probably
start at all oh you have an air term and
they're like oh I'm cutting your wings
you can't fly yeah so she has not been
grounded after this really weird video
will be the judge of the weird I think
you'll find this work okay
so don't either voices distorted
obviously I was like that she's hot
oh she's taking her tights off doesn't
seem weird so far yeah she wearing her
nametag you idiot yeah oh my god she
says well maybe well I don't mind me
after a long flight or something no the
first thing she said all day
so it seems like something you give to
your boyfriend now what she's sniffing
it
what's her own wasn't sure what she's
you smoosh video she's smelling her
tights and her uh I was probably being
sold to like those fetish dudes probably
making money off of it oh is that what
it is yeah I thought maybe someone was
sitting there or something no I thought
it was for her boyfriend or something I
could smell it through the screen it
smells and asked me to and no weird
smell like feet just tell on the plane
no no she's in a hotel room you know
it's funny that's wrong with it the last
thing the last thing was the cleavage
thing and that's like mildly like
average yeah and everything else is like
it's first started off as the most
parkour [ __ ] yes now my own [ __ ]
crotch yeah this is what she said cuz
her voice was deserted started she said
don't look at how rough
look after the flight so you want me to
smell my shoes and my tights well first
of all I've got to take the tights off
these I've been wearing all day with no
knickers just for you
listen [ __ ] that's what they call
underwears in UK and then I wasn't sure
what shoes you wanted me to smell it's
like the NIC huh Oh knickerbockers yeah
I thought those are pants so I know
we're very open-minded people in this
room so it's not that was interesting
this is what we do on JK party as a
punishment yeah we do actually but by
other people [ __ ] your own [ __ ] is not
really a punishment unless it's Bart's
[ __ ] true I don't know when I walk
around all day long I do not want to
smell my own feet that'll be a
punishment to you smelling your own feet
or someone else's feet same scenario
well someone else is worse yeah but
they're both punishments for you I
should not even bet it's just that she
was in her uniform like an idiot yeah
yeah that's why she got in trouble as
the uniform because you could see what
airline she works for and the fact that
they've grounded her for this as well
you're not that it was weird [ __ ] was
robbing money they thought it was yeah
it was they get her a race I saw it it's
just bad association with the company
yeah yeah dude if they did that after
hours no one's gonna give a [ __ ] yeah
there's like I don't have a logo you
should have bought a Halloween flight
attendant outfit no I just take off the
tags both of them or maybe just buy the
uniform itself you could probably tell I
saw a tweet with some chick was like
this dude paid me $5,000 to send me sent
him a video of my feet I was like [ __ ]
I'm down give me his phone 9gag
a little bit okay so follow them on
Instagram now they're posting a lot of
videos on their IG starting there's this
one where this guy's in his car right
and he's like filming it oh [ __ ] yes you
saw it the guy in the truck yeah this
guy in the truck with his wife and you
see they're at a red light and the guy
he looks like he's at least like 50
something yeah and his wife's foot is
like this on his lap and he's like
sucking it like a dick and he's putting
the whole
yeah really easy she's just chillin on
her phone like oh she's so used to it
and did he see I had the sound off did
he scream something yeah but guys
filming I was like turned around like
and he just yeah like nothing he like
the hopper like this part of her foot in
his mouth like all of and you think I'm
weird
yes are you into that yeah I mean that's
extremely weird but like you're so weird
I'm long imagine like an aggressive
sloppy [ __ ] but on a foot he was like
yeah I watched it like five times cause
I'm like this is it's so weird that were
all the views come from me because it
was just so surreal to me that I'm like
it's in broad daylight their windows are
down the wipe it like I was studying
every single thing like the wife is just
on her phone like she didn't give a [ __ ]
I was like what closed doors then I
heard it what Ryan might have been like
a hooker though that's why should your
brush he look like a wife way like
they've been look like a couple being a
broad daylight weird but like I'm not
any of that but that what if they want
to do it on their own it's not that
weird there's way it's not there's way
weirder but it was like broad daylight
yeah that's weird like he wasn't trying
to hide it like he didn't go down here
we're like you just see the top of his
head the steering wheel is here and his
hearse her foot is in his mouth and
weird she's not into it the funny thing
is the way she looked at the dude that
was recording afterwards they she was
insulted like why are you so weird for
recording us yeah she looks like she was
a weirdo
yeah it was so strange
[Music]